are you merciful Emma phobias rule
brothers and sisters and the only way to
tackle that is by educating this people
teaching them the King pure way of Islam
and an evidence to that it's one for the
sisters we get messages from the
Islamophobes exes Lama folks who hated
Islam by messaging us and telling us
your videos your discussions your
dialogues with the people has opened our
eyes to the true message of Islam and we
are sorry and we are people who come to
speaker's corner who visit us personally
and say thank you and forgive me all you
have to do is join this movement help us
in engaging people building cohesion
within communities by clicking the link
below
one click can change a person's whole
life are we going to be only known for
helping humanitarian causes while Islam
is under attack brothers and sisters
it's time we also help those in the
frontline educating people about the
true essence of Islam donate now to the
Dawa and help us reach millions of
hearts what are you waiting for
Salaam alaikum what happened to like
that ahead